this is another reason why you need to
start reading the labels very carefully
because of the assumption that just
because something is keto friendly like
stevia it's healthy right well a lot of
the brands out there they'll have things
like multi dextran now that is an
oxymoron because you're buying stevia to
go low sugar right when the actual
stevia it has the absolute highest type
of sweetener on the glycemic index of
all the sweeteners Multi duction I think
it's like a hundred and ten I mean think
about like sucrose that is 65 glucose is
a hundred melted dextran is over like a
hundred and ten so it's gonna definitely
spike your blood sugars so you really
want to make sure it doesn't say multi
dextran or dextrose or dextran any of
those types of sweeteners now that's
Stevie on the raw sweet leaf has inulin
which is fine for most people but it can
create some bloating and then you have
better stevia organic cane alcohol well
I'm not sure you want to consume that
then you have pure stevia which is
organic stevia and natural flavors one
little point about natural flavorings is
many times they will use GMO ingredients
so you want to make sure if it's a
natural flavoring that's non GMO but for
the most part if you can just get stevia
by itself it's going to be okay
ideally it'd be great if you can get
stevia that's actually green it's not
turning to this white powder which they
use certain chemicals to bleach it and
of course they don't need to put those
chemicals in the label if it's under a
half of a gram but they do use chemicals
to process stevia to get rid of that
aftertaste on some people they're gonna
react to it most people are not going to
be sensitive to it so it's not a big
deal but realize that if you do react to
it chances are you're not going to react
to the actual stevia plant if you grow
it or if you buy in actual green powder
personally I don't like stevia in my
coffee I think it's good in a liquid
form in certain types of
native beverages other people like to
bake with it but the point about this
video is just because something is so
cold kitto friendly doesn't mean that
it's really keto friendly if it has
things like this and it's thanks for
watching so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications